- I've never had any type
of vegetarian alternative
to anything, so...
- You've never had a veggie burger?
- What is that?
(upbeat music)
- I love everything about
like, not just the sushi,
I love ginger, I love wasabi.
- Yeah.
- My sister gave me a spoon of wasabi
when I was a little kid, and I
think I just became addicted.
- That's kinda messed up.
- I was a vegetarian for four years,
and then I had to make
an exception for sushi,
so I became pescatarian.
- Now, since my girlfriend
is recently a vegetarian,
now I've been looking all around the city
for vegetarian restaurants
that both me and her
can get food at.
- I've had very sad vegetarian sushi,
which is why I became pescatarian.
- If it tasted just like sushi,
I'd be happy with vegetarian sushi.
- Maybe I can eat a little bit less fish
and be kinder to the earth.
- Hey guys, my name is Guy.
I'm the chef and owner of Beyond Sushi.
(upbeat music)
I think of Beyond Sushi as something
that no one is doing out there.
It's first healthy and not just vegan,
because not all vegan food
is healthy necessarily.
We don't fry anything.
And everything is balanced and unique,
so you won't find these
combinations anywhere else.
For me, it's all about the package
and the balance between
the flavors when you eat
and colors and textures and
everything that comes with it.
Spicy Mang has black rice,
English cucumber, avocado,
mango on the inside, it's topped off
with semi-pickled cabbage,
carrots, and peppers.
- (Max) So spicy mango is
one of my favorite flavors,
so I'm excited about this one.
- It looks very fancy.
I love the little dollops of
sauce on top, that's so cute.
- The plating is beautiful,
let's get that right.
So already we're beyond sushi
in one sense of the word.
I think it's delicious.
I don't know if I would feel
like I was eating sushi.
I feel like I'm in my own
kind of like food now.
Although I guess like the
experience we're having
of the way we just ate it
makes it really sushi-like.
- I love the spice of it, it
has a really nice kick to it.
- It also tastes really
healthy, vegetarianism aside.
- The La Fiesta has sliced chayote,
pickled jalapenos, avocado,
and it's topped off
with a black bean puree,
tomato guajillo sauce, and
a kefir leaf lime chips.
- Beauty, man, beauty, okay?
- This is very Instagrammable.
- Yeah.
- It has like the same consistency
as if it had fish in it.
I literally cannot tell the difference.
- Yeah, I can't tell that
it doesn't have fish also.
Because it has like some
kind of fish seasoning.
- I also feel like this could
be like a good breakfast,
lunch, or dinner, like
any time of the day.
- Even like midnight
snack when you have like
that guilty conscience, and you're like,
oh I'm gonna get up right
now and grab something like,
having two of these at like
3 o'clock in the morning,
I feel like you'll be okay.
I don't really eat that much vegetables,
so the fact that I'm just
eating rolled up vegetables,
it's like surprisingly so amazing.
(upbeat music)
- Pickle Me has six grain
rice on the outside,
marinated carrots, pickled yamagobo,
which is a burdock root pickled daikon,
and it's topped off with an avocado layer
and a carrot ginger sauce.
- Did you say burdock root, Bodak Yellow?
- I don't even know what
half of this stuff is.
I've never even heard of these vegetables.
- But I think that's the cool
thing about vegetarian options
is because once you start to explore them,
you start to explore all these
different types of vegetables
that you never knew existed.
- And so many different flavors.
It actually looks like
there's raw fish in there,
do you see that?
I'm excited, it smells
like seafood though.
- No, it don't.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I smell the seaweed, that's what it is.
- That shit is bomb.
- It's like still coming in,
like flavors are still coming.
- And the texture kind of reminds me
of like yellowtail, so that's cool.
- It's sweet.
It's like ginger carrot.
Mm, this is the D and Eric approved move.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- I don't know any
vegetarians unfortunately,
but I think anybody would love this place.
- My favorite part of sushi is
always like the mango on top
or like the different
flavors that they add
to the actual sushi.
And this is just like a combination
of all the good toppings.
- Speaking as a not vegetarian,
I think this would be such
a great place to get dinner
with a vegan or vegetarian friend.
It kinda reminds you that
there's a lot about sushi
that's not in the sushi, in
the fish itself ironically.
- I really enjoyed this experience.
As someone who is mostly vegetarian,
someone who usually
eats plant-based things,
I love all the flavors,
I love how beautiful the rolls looked,
they are much better
than a sad cucumber roll.
And I would come back, I
definitely would come back.
- It's awesome, you can
have healthier sushi
and healthier pockets,
who wouldn't want that?
(upbeat music)